complaints about the millennial
generation are a common or frame which
doesn't help Millennials feel confident
in their value to society but
Millennials should know how important
their voices and votes are today's young
people volunteer more than old people
they are better educated and they are
less likely to drink excessively and use
drugs than previous generations of youth
is that that's super positive I love
that America's most racially diverse
generation some 43 percent of millennial
adults are non-white the highest share
of any generation Millennials have
surpassed baby boomers as the nation's
largest living generation guys need to
listen to us essentially yes New York
Times did a study and found that there's
ample evidence that young people today
are hardworking and very productive the
share of college students working full
time generally grew from 1985 onward and
only went down during the Great
Recession it knocked many Millennials
out of the workforce between 1989 and
2006 the share of teenagers who were
volunteering doubled to 26.4%
from 13.4% Clark University research in
a recent survey of 18 to 29 year olds
86% agreed that it is important to me to
have a career that does some good in the
world that's amazing I know that's
really nice
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]